Leonie der grausame Mord an einer
13-Jährigen das Mädchen wird unter
Drogen gesetzt brutal von drei Männern
vergewaltigt erstickt schließlich an
ihrer Überdosis wird in einen Teppich
eingerollt und Tod an einen Baum gelehnt
ihr Körper übersät mit Blutergüssen
heute startet der Prozess gegen die drei
brutalen mädchenkiller aus Österreich
die Anklageschrift ist 16 Seiten lang
sie offenbart das Versagen der Behörden
und das Grauen dieser Tatnacht
Leonie 13 Jahre alt stundenlang wird sie
vergewaltigt von mehreren Männern so
lange bis sie stirbt das tragische
Schicksal das Mädchens sorgt im Juni
2021 für Betroffenheit Grabkerzen am
Baum an dem die leblose Leonie abgelegt
wurde eine Augenzeuge erinnert sich also
ich bin um 6:50 Uhr eben aufgestanden
bin rausgegangen wollte eine rauchen und
Kaffee dazu trinken als ich dann eben
runter geschaut habe um gesehen habe
dass da eben zwei Jugendliche und eine
Dame bei einer Frau also vom fernen saß
halt ich dachte es ist eine andere
Jugendliche die da eben am Baum lehnt
habe das halt eben beobachtet weil ich
dachte es ging ja auf kreislaufmäßig
nicht so gut
und nachdem sie aber dann irgendwie so
nach vorne gekippt ist habe ich dann
gemerkt dass das ernster ist um eine
Instagram Bekanntschaft zu treffen einen
16-Jährigen Afghanen fährt Leonie am 25
Juni nach Wien Fotos einer
Überwachungskamera zeigen Leonie und
zwei Männer auf dem Weg zur Wohnung
eines Dritten Afghanen es sind die
letzten Aufnahmen von Leonie
einer der Verdächtigen schildert am
nächsten Tag seinem bekannten Mohammed m
die Tat
und sie sagte sie wollte es nicht dann
haben sie sieben Stück in eine Flasche
getan 7 Stunden extra 7
und als Mädchen
in die Küche gegangen ist
und dann kommt der 16-Jährige Macht mit
dir
so hatte mehr der hat sie erzählt
dass ihr mit der Sache nicht zu tun hat
ja
und dann wurden sie Mädchen als sie
beide fertig waren die wurden sie wieder
wach machen sie geben sie ehren damit
und sie wissen quasi sie wissen dass sie
nicht funktioniert sie bringen sie in
der Dusche und die Schmerzen was auch
für dich sieht ob die Mädchen wird
langsam also die Eltern wohl bewusstlos
und dann langsam geatmet
muss ich dort war
sie nehmen Sie und ich meine sie nehmen
einen Baum
fest steht Leonie wird mit insgesamt bis
zu 11 exklusiv Tabletten ruhiggestellt
dann wird das benommene Mädchen 4
Stunden lang abwechselnd vergewaltigt
währenddessen erstickt sie an einer
Überdosis Mohammed m reagiert sofort
vereinbart ein Treffen und lockt so die
mädchenkiller in die polizeifalle bei
Bild TV kündigt der damalige
österreichische Bundeskanzler Sebastian
Kurz harte Maßnahmen und ganz wichtig
erscheint mir dass wir politisch einfach
konsequent sind gegenüber all jenen die
Verbrechen begehen gegen allen
Gewaltverbrechern vor allem gegenüber
Flüchtlingen die Straftaten begehen dass
es hier zu konsequenten Abschiebungen
kommt und wir hatten in Österreich auch
eine Debatte in Richtung Abschiebestopp
nach Afghanistan das wird es mit mir
sicherlich nicht geben
die 16-seitige Anklageschrift enthüllt
nicht nur lionis mehr thyrium sondern
auch das Versagen der Politik die
Kriminellen Angeklagten waren
einschlägig vorbestraft
[Musik]